my first encounter was really seeing his
records my dad had them my dad had a
very very large record collection and he
had almost every Mouse it was record um
so that that was just my first encounter
but I really didn't listen to his music
then and didn't really know who he was
and so all that really came in doing the
film finding out who the man really was
his music what he stood for all of that
came and doing the film and what did you
find him um I found out that he was a
man who really as it comes to his his
art refused to be put in any kind of box
he really lived on the out side of
authority you know anyone's authority in
terms of how something should sound how
something should look and that for me is
exciting you know in any kind of art
form a year you're not afraid to to fail
and to fall you know he didn't like
rehearsals you know he wants you to
perform when it's time to perform on
stage in front of the audience you know
and that is scary you know it's live
theatre it's scary but that is always
where you find the best bits and so for
me that's one of the exciting things
about mouths and his music did that
justify how he treated his wife your
your care character absolutely not
absolutely not you know and that's what
I find fascinating with people like
Miles Davis would have you who are able
to create this beautiful art that
connect that can connect to people but
at the same time have this other side in
the end of the day I believe that all of
us have that same thing within us
whether we act on it or not you know we
had the capability to go to that dark
place and it's especially common I think
I found with artists you know who have
great artists anyway who have the
ability to make this kind of art but
then how does this dark side you know
that's really fascinating and personal
what was the biggest challenge in making
this film in the actual homes and
working um I think one of my biggest
challenges was portraying someone who is
real life portraying Francis and the
desire to want to make sure that she's
happy with
betrayal but at the same time the desire
to make sure that my honest and true to
the work as well you know to tow that
line I think that was one of the big
challenges for me and I was really
reassured working with Don because he's
done many biopic you know many and he's
always been so good at them being able
to portray the truth who the person was
and so for me that was a blessing to
have him to kind of bounce ideas off of